François Beraud rien est réglé le
gouvernement n'a pas été renversé soit
le projet de loi sur la réforme des
retraites a été adoptée soit mais à quel
prix
bon c'est un peu de serrer et c'est pas
un triomphe de qui que ce soit parce que
le débat la coloration du débat que
Patrick Cohen a décrit très bien entre
les lignes le
tour que les choses ont prié par
satisfaisant
il y a eu une phrase qui qui m'a
intéressé ou sur laquelle je voudrais
réagir dans les interventions
réforme ni nécessaire ni juste à dire
l'une des intervenants
cette réforme était vitale je vais
essayer de dire pourquoi en une phrase
et la plus juste et si je puis dire
cette obligation de justice la rendait
vitale pourquoi en deux mots le
et le gouvernement n'a pas su
l'expliquer je le reconnais oui
François Bayon mais c'est un peu tard la
police ce n'est pas tard parce que comme
vous savez avec le Commissariat aux
planches j'ai publié une note sur pour
précisément apporter la preuve de ce que
je dis en décembre
on a entendu ici ou là que les retraites
étaient équilibrées c'est une blague et
c'est un mensonge immoral les retraites
elles dès aujourd'hui
le l'État le contribuable verse entre 30
et 40 milliards d'euros par an pour les
équilibrer ce qu'on a répété ici de
nombreux
si vous l'avez fait c'est bien parce que
beaucoup de gens ne l'ont pas fait mais
Patrick Cohen a de très bonnes lectures
et je le félicite pour ça et donc
or cet argent
si on l'avait
ça serait tout à fait possible plausible
on pourrait discuter pour dire c'est là
qu'il est le mieux utilisé après tout on
récompense ceux qui ont travaillé cet
argent nous ne l'avons pas nous
l'empruntons tous les ans et l'emprunter
ça veut dire le maître sur le dos des
plus jeunes des actifs actuels
et puis des encore plus jeune des actifs
comme ça n'a pas été à mon sens
présenté et défendu devant les Français
et cette
cette génération mettant de boomer comme
on dit cette génération qui fait payer
ses retraites
par ceux qui travaillent aujourd'hui et
travailleront demain ils pourront plus
assumer leur charge
éducation santé ils sont obligés de
prendre le la dette qu'on leur laisse
sur le dos ceci pour moi est malhonnête
et c'est immoral mais si le gouvernement
a échoué à convaincre ne faut-il pas en
tirer les conséquences si le
gouvernement échoué à convaincre nous
sommes là pour essayer de prendre le
relais et que cette idée soit comprise
ou entendu par tous parce que et que
finalement les Français se disent que
cette réforme est légitime contrairement
à ce qu'il pense aujourd'hui
évidemment il y aura d'autres épisodes
et il y aura d'autres réformes donc
c'est pas donc ça c'est le premier point
qu'il faut changer c'est le gouvernement
si je vous en dit non pas du tout
le gouvernement c'est la méthode
qui a été choisi et à mon sens qui n'a
pas été porté poussé comme elle aurait
dû la lettre il y a une deuxième chose
on a laissé entendre que ce fameux
article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
n'était pas
démocratique or comme vous le voyez il
remet entre les mains des élus de la
nation le sort du gouvernement s'il
pense qu'il y a quelque chose d'injuste
il renverse le gouvernement il n'y a pas
plus
plus importantes plus grande
responsabilité que celle là c'est
d'ailleurs
sous la Quatrième République avant
d'arriver à la cinquième Togo après a
repris cette idée c'est des responsables
de gauche et du centre de l'époque qui
ont imposé ce fameux pédagogie tardive
trop tardive sur cette réforme de
retraite va convaincre les Français qui
n'en veulent pas que cette loi est
nécessaire et qui ne pardonneront pas au
débat démocratique de ne pas avoir eu
lieu à l'Assemblée pensant que c'est le
gouvernement qui
a eu lieu pendant des centaines d'heures
il a eu lieu dans une ambiance
détestable honteuse qui fait honte vous
savez il y a plein de députés qui sont
absolument bon ils avaient signé ils
étaient présentés pour ça mais ils sont
profondément traumatisés par ce qui
s'est passé et beaucoup de Français sont
aussi profondément traumatisées et donc
ceci ouvre une responsabilité de
nouvelles parce qu'en effet question a
été très justement en effet la question
c'est est-ce que nous pouvons trouver ou
pas une méthode pour réformer le pays
qui ne soit pas dans cette explosion
attendue
vécu et entretenu mais vous vous voyez
bien l'ampleur des des colères et des
oppositions aujourd'hui dans le pays
vous l'avez si je puis dire vu sans
doute vu de près parce qu'on a plusieurs
fois cités la ville de Pau à chaque
mobilisation à chaque journée
interprofessionnel pour a eu des
milliers de manifestants dans les rues à
une mesure que sans doute la ville
n'avait jamais connu donc vous avez vu
c'est pas vrai si à une mesure vous
connaissez la sensibilité politique de
la ville c'est une c'est une ville qui
est qui est de ce point de vue là
éruptive elle a longtemps été social
très
et donc cette cette sensibilité là
oui elle s'est exprimée et elle a bien
raison de je veux dire si on aime la
démocratie comme moi on accepte qu'il y
ait du débat qu'on a cette qui est
contestation et c'est une très juste et
très bonne chose simplement ce qu'il
faut quand il y a un débat de cette
difficulté c'est pouvoir en sortir et
précisément il y a il y a un papier très
intéressant ce matin sur le site Telos
avec Gérard Grimbert qui est Grimbert
qui est un qui est un spécialiste de ces
sujets qui remarquable il dit le 49.3
c'est la sauvegarde d'un régime
parlementaire
il avait été inventé pour ça pourquoi
parce qu'autrement le Parlement c'est
une explosion perpétuelle ça devient
illisible et les Français se détournent
de ça et donc le fait qu'à un moment
puisse dire on va trancher
chacun va prendre ses responsabilités le
gouvernement vous dit ce texte est pour
moi vital pour le pays les opposants
disent ce texte nous n'en voulons pas
chacun va au bout et on a des votes
comme ce soir au moins les
parlementaires ont pris la
responsabilité mais il n'empêchait
Elizabeth borne en ressort extrêmement
fragilisé est-ce qu'elle peut rester
encore longtemps première ministre elle
est fille d'un côté le rassemblement
national de l'autre ce soir réclame sa
démission c'est un gouvernement un Tim
a-t-il panneau pour la France
d'un côté et de rassemblement national
de l'autre ça ne fait pas une majorité
rassurante moi je ne dis pas c'est le
président de la République qui choisit
qui est il analyse la situation
il le fait je crois avec beaucoup de
soucis de ce qui se passe il analyse le
montre pas beaucoup à l'opinion
je m'exprime à titre personnel
montre pas et peut-être l'occasion
peut-être aura-t-il l'occasion de le
montrer très vite
et donc
je parle d'une intervention
je sais pas si votre date est exacte
mais il doit présenter son analyse de la
situation dire ce qu'il a ressenti
expliqué les choix qui ont été faits en
quelques phrases mais simplement pour
montrer que tout ça avait du sens et il
doit commencer à ouvrir des portes sur
une nouvelle étape je crois que que
c'est que c'est absolument logique qu'il
fasse une nouvelle étape c'est-à-dire
une nouvelle étape institutionnelle ou
de nouveaux projets une nouvelle équipe
ou un je vais dire ce que je pense et
c'est moi qui le pense c'est pas la
majorité c'est pas c'est pas une affaire
de partie
je pense que l'élection présidentielle
n'a pas totalement rempli la mission qui
doit être la sienne de montrer au pays
où on veut aller donc il doit faire
campagne
elle s'est focalisée cette élection
précisément sur la réforme des retraites
or la réforme des retraites n'est pas
comme on dit français l'alpha ou en grec
l'alpha et l'oméga de tout ce que nous
avons à faire réforme des retraites
était indispensable pour la raison que
j'ai dite de fragilisation incroyable de
de notre équilibre social mais
beaucoup est à reconstruire
on est devant un immense chantier de
reconstruction relative à l'Assemblée
nationale à la menace de motion de
censure à répétition et ce qui pourrait
être voté et ne pas être rejeté
si on s'arrête une seconde pour
réfléchir ensemble au défi que nous
avons devant nous l'éducation qui est
dans un état c'est un sujet que j'aime
beaucoup qui est très important pour moi
l'éducation est dans un état inquiétant
il y a des soucis importants autour de
la santé il y a des soucis importants
autour de l'organisation de l'état de
l'action publique de et tout ça
constitue on va avoir jean-jousel dans
une minute le le la stratégie de la
nation et des nations qui nous entourent
face au réchauffement climatique et
c'est un sujet très très important
on peut on ne peut pas s'arrêter au
point où ce soir nous sommes arrivés à
ce qu'il peut vraiment y aller à cette
nouvelle étape quand on voit ce qui se
passe il y avait des pancarres
rendez-vous dans la rue et les Français
ils sont dans la rue ils sont opposés à
cette réforme ils le disent encore ce
matin il y avait des manifestations pour
protester contre la réforme des
retraites et contre l'usage du 49-3
comme par exemple à Rennes qui avait
lancé une opération ville morte vous ne
permettez de la seule manière
aujourd'hui de contrecarrer un peu le
gouvernement et lui montrer qu'on n'est
pas d'accord c'est c'est de bloquer le
pays et d'être présent un petit café
pour patienter
vous voulez un café non non ils prennent
normalement je pense qu'ici attendait
c'est pas je sais pas pourquoi ils sont
là d'ailleurs
[Musique]
je comprends pas du tout parce que nous
on a travaillé toute notre vie vous
savez c'est très difficile il faut
bloquer mais là faut que j'aille au
boulot quoi il faut tout le monde se
battent après on a pas toujours la
possibilité de faire grève mais ouais
non je soutiens
aujourd'hui on est tous mobilisés
montrer notre opposition à la réforme
des retraites et surtout aussi au
passage en force du gouvernement avec le
49-3
à 60 ans malheureusement il y a un
moment bah ouais on arrive jusqu'au
blocage et c'est notre 49-3 donc ouais
on va bloquer et puis on bloquera le
temps qu'il faudra François a eu des
débordements ce week-end à Paris mais
aussi dans d'autres villes est-ce que
vous ne craignez pas un embrasement de
la colère sociale
ça peut toujours se produire faut jamais
avoir un jugement péremptoire mais je
pense que non nous n'en sommes pas là
vous avez dit tout à l'heure le pays est
contre une partie du pays est contre une
majorité de Français majorité de
Français dans les sondages mais le
nombre les majorités constituées dans
les sondages ça n'est pas le ce n'est
pas le très fond de ces choses je pense
que c'est pas d'aujourd'hui que je dis
ça on a à reconstruire le la démarche
politique la démarche citoyenne
elle est pour l'instant atomisée explosé
bloqué
les trois à la fois on peut pas se
contenter de ça et on peut pas se
contenter de baisser les bras en disant
bon c'est la faute du gouvernement
ce que je crois profondément c'est que
tout le monde a sa part de fautes
le pouvoir
majorité mais les oppositions aussi
on peut on peut faire le tour de du
paysage politique pour l'instant et ce
sera la grande question des années qui
viennent on a pas réussi à formuler un
espoir crédible pour
les français pour ceux qui vous écoutent
et qui nous écoutent
je dois dire d'ailleurs que
je crois que le ton de votre émission
est apprécié pour cette raison là c'est
pas pour vous faire des compliments j'en
fais jamais comme vous savez mais là je
pense que que ce que vous exprimez pas
seulement par les mots que vous utilisez
ou les thèmes que vous choisissez mais
par le ton que vous avez choisi et
positif pour cette question de là
comment trouver une nouvelle démarche
dans laquelle les gens se reconnaissent
se traduit comment François Bayer
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron a encore le
crédit et la capacité de rebond pour
impulser ce que vous décrivez là qui est
un diagnostic assez partagé sur l'état
de de fracture du pays mais la personne
du président de la République
aujourd'hui a vu son crédit sérieusement
entamé ça on le voit dans le à la fois
dans les enquêtes de Vignaux et pas
seulement en écoutant la rue si vous me
permettez j'ai vécu beaucoup un certain
nombre de présidents de la République
nous avons vécu ici un certain nombre de
présidents de la République un populaire
à un point qu'on peut même pas imaginer
et puis qui après ont retrouvé du crédit
dans le reste de leur mandat et a
fortiori après leur mandat donc t'as
rien je peux citer je regarde je
regardais Pierre Lescure dans les yeux
François Mitterrand a été détesté à un
moment Jacques Chirac a été haïr un
moment je ne parle que de ceux qui ne
sont plus là je pourrais aller un peu
plus loin après et puis ils ont retrouvé
du crédit parce que
il y a deux choses
je crois que
l'esprit public psychiatrise
et puis je crois aussi que de nouvelles
inspirations viennent et je suis
persuadé qu'il va falloir maintenant
exprimer faire entendre cette nouvelle
inspiration là quoi je crois ça dans les
jours qui viennent
une dissolution ni par un nouveau grand
débat de que va pouvoir inventer le
président de la République là où il n'a
pas convaincu jusque-là là où il n'a pas
fait campagne pour les précédentes les
dernières présidentielles ce qui lui a
été
que c'est le grand enjeu je pense qu'il
y a des questions
extrêmement profondes même si on ne sait
pas les exprimer que les Français se
posent en leur fort intérieur par
exemple
la très grande question du modèle
français on parle social on est le pays
le plus généreux du monde en matière de
redistribution sociale et cependant
on a le sentiment que
tout cet effort s'enlise au fur et à
mesure qu'on avance et que dans ce pays
pour qui les services publics sont
vraiment
un idéal partagé plus on avance moins on
est satisfait des services publics et le
sentiment assez souvent que plus on met
des moyens et moins ça marche alors je
fais pas de relation entre les deux
comme vous comprenez mais yes il y a
cette interrogation profonde ce que nous
croyons être l'idéal français
qu'on a adopté soutenu ovationner
quelquefois en tout cas toujours
souligner dans les dernières décennies
aujourd'hui on a besoin de le redéfinir
et ça ça ne peut pas se faire en effet
sans que les grandes forces
démocratiques singulièrement le dans
l'arc central qui qui vont de
des socialistes de gouvernement jusque
au gaulliste de gouvernement cette
immense arc centrale là il a sa
responsabilité et c'est une
responsabilité première il a des
problèmes du président de la République
ce sera aussi de retisser si c'est
possible un dialogue avec les
partenaires sociaux car ce que la
rupture semble consommer y compris avec
leur envergers
c'est une situation qui pour ma part me
cause du souci parce que je crois que
quand je parlais de l'arc central dans
cet arc central il y a les forces
réformistes
qui ont qui ont toujours
assurés regardez
les choses en disant on veut pas tout
casser on veut pas tout mettre par terre
mais nous savons nous pensons qu'on peut
corriger et réorienter
ce dialogue a été oui un peu escamoté
escamoté ces derniers temps ces derniers
temps vous voyez la dimension vous
demandiez qu'est-ce que doit dire le
président de la République
voilà une dimension des de ce qu'il
devra dire au pays je crois vous restez
avec nous François Baro parce que
beaucoup d'autres
avec les dirigeants politiques Greta
Steinberg et les accusent de trahison là
c'est sa réaction aujourd'hui au rapport
du GIEC c'est vrai que Monsieur Joseph
reste très courtois à votre égard mais
peut-être vous auriez des raisons d'en
vouloir ou dire les gens politiques en
quelques mots
notre invitation
je crois que les solutions existent
que pour certaines d'entre elles elles
sont à portée de la main sont faciles je
vais en citer une sur laquelle nous
venons avec le Commissariat aux plans de
d'établir une analyse
sous nos pieds nous avons un réservoir
inépuisable et gratuit pour baisser
la consommation des maisons et des
appartements c'est la géothermie sous
nos pieds à quelques mètres sous nos
pieds on divise par 5 la quantité
d'électricité nécessaire pour se
chauffer et par 10 8 10 50 la quantité
d'électricité nécessaire pour rafraîchir
les maisons c'est immédiatement
disponible c'est des outils extrêmement
simples qui existent qui sont tous
disponibles et qui ne sont pas chers ou
en tout cas
par rapport aux économies qu'ils vont
faire faire y compris aux familles qui
les utiliseront c'est immédiatement
disponible et il va il va en effet
falloir que nous passions le stade
d'aller des paroles jusque aux actes et
ça c'est on n'a pas besoin de recherche
c'est immédiatement là et 95% du
territoire français qui peut utiliser la
chaleur ou la fraîcheur du sous-sol
voilà l'une des solutions que vous
apportez ce soir à cette question vous
restez